but let's have a go at this proof okay
now
correct me you might need to hold my
hand a little bit because it's short but
i only looked at it like once or twice
okay
so i think we always have to start with
something we know
we always have to start with something
new and in this case what we started
with was
we defined a function but then we could
say things about it because of calculus
right
if you don't go calculus the only thing
you know is this
that's all you know right so you say
well okay
x is greater than one where can i go
with this thing okay
well that means that x minus one is
greater than zero right right
all i did was subtract one from both
sides okay now x minus one
that's not so helpful to me because i
don't have an x minus 1 here i have a 1
minus x
so what's the difference between those
it's a factor of minus 1. so if i slap
them
division by x minus 1 on that side
i change the inequality
all right you see how clever this is
right uh
i don't actually want a one minus six on
its own i want a
ten inverse so what happens if i take
tan inverse of both sides
now i'm just going to put in the
operation
right and i'm not going to fill in the
inequality yet
which way would the inequality go
because it's not obvious
now tan inverse of zero we just did this
right ten inverse of zero
sure enough is zero which way does the
inequality go
so i have this and this thing is
negative well if it's negative
then surely it's also less than one
right you've got to be careful here
they're inequalities
that's why i'm not adding one to both
sides i'm just saying
you know if negative two is less than
zero well that means it's less than one
as well
right i'm shorter than this guy so i'm
shorter than this other guy who's tall
okay all right i'm almost there almost
there
one one what do i know about one i don't
know very much right
but i do know that x is bigger than one
right right
so therefore look i'm going to do
exactly the same thing
10 inverse is less than zero well this
guy's taller so i'm less than him as
well
well this guy is even taller so i'm less
than him
as well oh snap
so so there's the result now
i think i haven't thought about this
long enough because i just saw it and in
fact this proof is
longer than yours by like three lines
because i added in some extra things
just to pat it out a little bit right
i think if there's an issue with this
well which line do you think the issue
would be
i challenge this okay look line one two
three four five six seven
where do you think from which line to
which line
so i think from three to four is is the
question
right because like i just showed you
look only for this little part
like i know this is tan though right
because ten inverse and tan are not the
same beast
right so i'll let you have a think about
it
okay but i really i really like it i
mean in davin's proof i think he skipped
this line
because it's fairly trivial and i think
he also skipped
you skipped something else as well i
don't know it was short very short
no calculus look mum no calculus okay so
thumbs up from me